even though he doesn't join the fray
until more than
midway through zack snyder's justice
league on hbo max
superman's big return is one of the
movie's most pivotal scenes
however it's not nearly as important as
what comes
after the hero's resurrection after the
justice league uses one of the mother
boxes to resurrect clark
he wakes up disoriented and tears
through the team at heroes park
until lois lane calms him down
afterwards he heads to the farm with
lois in order to come to terms with his
return from the dead
before heading to his ship to pick out a
suit to wear into battle
as he walks through his ship clark hears
the voices of his fathers
jorel and jonathan kent offering him
advice and urging him to show the world
love
and mercy as they speak the ship offers
clark an array of suits to choose from
including his classic red and blue
number but he ultimately settles on the
black one
on the surface superman's decision to
don a black suit
feels ominous after all the color black
is most often associated with death and
mourning but
in clark's case the choice is all about
rebirth and
embracing his kryptonian heritage
something both of his fathers have urged
him to do
the most important part of this pivotal
scene isn't the black suit itself
it's superman's reason for choosing it
snyder's decision to have jonathan and
jorel's words
overlapped create one cohesive message
for their son
is crucial to the emotional impact of
the moment even though his fathers are
two very different
men their messages say the same thing we
love you
we're proud of you you have to stay
strong and you can't lose yourself
at one point jorel says
all the hopes and dreams of krypton live
in you now
meanwhile jonathan urges clark to show
the world his true self
he explains you're gonna have to make a
choice a choice of whether to stand
proud in front of the human race or not
you need to show them who you are ever
since he was a child clark has been
hiding part of himself he's either clark
kent the wholesome son of martha and
jonathan
or he's kal-el an alien among humans
whose powers make it impossible for him
to ever be seen as anything
other than superman but the truth is
clark is both of these people at once
by choosing the black suit a suit rooted
in his kryptonian heritage
clark is finally taking a step toward
embracing his history as he fights to
save humanity even though he's already
made the ultimate sacrifice once
in the comics superman wears the black
suit also known as the recovery suit
after his resurrection because it will
help him physically heal but
in the film he doesn't need to recharge
his powers after returning from the dead
as evidenced by the way he absolutely
destroys the justice league at heroes
park
in fact snyder never makes any mention
of the black suit possessing
any special abilities or attributes at
all for clark the black suit is more of
a metaphor
than anything else in an extensive
interview with eye minutemen
snyder delved into the meaning behind
superman's decision not to immediately
return to his famous red and blue outfit
the director explained the black suit
you can say that in modern krypton when
he left
everyone was wearing black suits so it
is sort of linked to
in some ways the old world i think it's
a more direct relationship to his family
in a lot of ways the blue suit to me
represents this place on earth
the blue suit is his suit of a hero the
suit of his destiny whereas the black
suit
is more personal in a lot of ways more
about his family
one is outward and one is inward a big
part of the original vision of the
justice league trilogy would have been
tied to superman's character arc
as he slowly became the stalwart hero
fans know from the comics and left
behind the more conflicted man he is in
the modern day films
during an interview with comic book
debate snyder explained his thought
process behind putting superman in the
black suit
and where he wanted to take the
character in subsequent films
the director said superman had to at
every step
sort of level up and learn something and
be something different
what i had planned was that the final
step for superman
was his real return or his real coming
into what i would consider the classic
superman we don't really get it in this
movie the classic
superman instead fans are given a raw
version of superman who heads into
battle even though he's still reeling
from being brought back from the dead
in the end the black suit scene is about
showing clark at his most
vulnerable moment deciding that he's not
going to hide who he really is from the
world anymore
while he understands the comfort his red
and blue suit brings to the people of
earth
at this point in his story he knows he
can't go back to who he was before his
death
all he can do now is move forward in a
way that honors his family
and for now at least that means rocking
the
very kryptonian black suit check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about the dc eu
are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]